is there a double standard at the
highest levels of law enforcement
joining me now the editor-in-chief of
The Daily wire Ben Shapiro welcome back
then yeah thanks for having me so what
do you make of this letter signed off by
eleven congressmen and one woman so I
obviously agreed that there was a double
standard applied by the FBI and the DOJ
between the Obama days and the and the
Trump days it's pretty obvious that the
FBI and the DOJ particularly DOJ under
President Obama were operating as
adjuncts to the Obama agenda in Eric
Holder who's the Attorney General under
Obama was openly calling himself the
wingman for President Obama at the same
time he was being held in contempt by
Congress so it's hard to argue that
there wasn't some sort of corruption
happening at the DOJ in terms of helping
to cover up whatever crimes may have
been committed by the Obama
administration and as far as the FBI I
don't think the congressmen are wrong to
point out the fact that James Comey had
apparently pre decided the the outcome
of the Hillary Clinton investigation
it's pretty obvious that they were
allowing certain leeway to Hillary
Clinton they wouldn't have allowed to
anyone else the most obvious example
being the allowance of Cheryl Mills
Hillary's really hatchet person yeah to
to claim attorney-client privilege
allowing her in the room with Hillary
during the interview claiming she was
her attorney when Cheryl Mills was
intimately involved with the cleansing
of Hillary Clinton's email I'm really
glad you brought that up because the
relationship with Cheryl Mills is
something that I've always found to be
very concerning because you know does
attorney-client privilege exist when you
just know someone who's an attorney or
someone happens to be an attorney yet
they wear a different hat in their
professional life with you and you know
part of the part of the justification
for the Michael Cohen hotel home and
office raid was well he really doesn't
have that many clients so
attorney-client privilege doesn't really
exist well Cheryl Mills was acting as
Hillary Clinton's campaign manager so
why did they allow for attorney-client
privilege there yeah that's a serious
question Andrew McCarthy at national
view raised it a year ago and it really
has not been answered and it does show
the discrepancy between the treatment
the question is was the FBI and the DOJ
what were they corrupt then or are they
corrupt now or both and it's possible
that they were corrupt then and not
corrupt now and one of the problems now
is that if you have Jeff Sessions who I
think is an honest Attorney General and
if you have a new FBI director who
think is attempting to do the right
thing and Chris Rea and if they're doing
the right thing now does that look
corrupt because they're not doing what
they did before right is the discrepancy
the problem in other words if we thought
that the Obama DOJ and FBI were corrupt
do people on the right now want the FBI
and the DOJ to be tools of the trump
administration in the same way that
there were tools of the Obama
administration you're absolutely wanted
to have it both ways
I mean that that is a natural
contradiction that is playing itself out
right now and it's leading to the kind
of chaos and the kind of turmoil that
anytime a decision is made it is
automatically shot down by one side as
being wholly political so how do we get
back to the point where we don't have to
revere these institutions we don't have
to unnaturally idealize them but when
can we actually trust them again I mean
honestly I think that if the if the
Trump administration FBI and DOJ can go
after anybody they should really be
looking at people like Eric Holder and
Loretta Lynch I think that those those
would be the most obvious sources of
corruption as far as looking at past FBI
behavior I think investigations might be
warranted I'm not proud I'm not sure
prosecution's you think company's in
trouble again I think I think they call
me they're serious questions to be asked
about James Comey I mean the fact that
he was leaking material while denying
that he was leaking material is
obviously a serious problem you know
that that's been overlooked by the media
in their attempts to paint him as some
sort of white knight hero who's coming
in to save the Republic from Donald
Trump no he said that Andrew McCabe did
the exact same thing and was called on
it and fired for it he condemned that
but he also did exactly what he's
condemning so you know does there need
to be a reciprocity I don't know if it's
gonna happen I love justice Ben Shapiro
thank you so much for joining me I
appreciate it thanks a lot